joining us back here on the rich housing
show is one of our favorites um
he's been in the league forever and a
day
first round selection back in 2011 we
were talking about the 2010 draft right
um and this man is a man who is the 24th
overall pick of the
2011 national football league draft by
way of cal coming to us from new orleans
the new orleans saints defensive end one
of our favorites cameron jordan back
here on the show how are you doing
cameron
i'm good man just finished up with
practice for the day yes can't uh can't
be more blessed okay how to walk me
through what a practice looks like
middle of august getting ready for a
season
what is it what does it look like
i was i don't even
middle of august i don't even know what
day today is
we need to clean up right and that's
that's what creases them for and
help us edge off you know all of our
faults i guess how does the cleanup look
like walk me through the process of
cleaning up like uh meetings stuff like
that i mean uh again i'm just trying to
give people an idea of what it's like to
be an nfl veteran uh on a team with so
many hopes and wishes and question marks
quite frankly we're going into a season
right
um yeah i mean there's plenty but i mean
get down to it
process of you know creating more
turnovers from the defense side this is
the practice of uh you know we had a
couple off-sides some of these happen
for our d-line that we focused on so
especially today um
you know keeping the ball high and tight
and always having you know five points
of contact on the ball um
but at this point you know it's just
it's just getting better each and every
day and knowing your repertoire between
you and your interior deep in the line
so we can get a better pass risk
happening well one of the videos that
came out of practice uh that went a
little bit viral uh cam jordan was uh
jameis winston uh with techno dancing uh
where were you when he was doing
something like that where were you i was
i was probably i was probably reading
the banks i was just something myself
james just happened to be uh
i mean but you know that's what happened
he married he got kids you know you know
when you get to vegas sometimes you
gotta do a little help okay uh and
that's definitely something you never
saw from breeze right at any point over
the last 15 years i'm sure it was you
know
drew just stays in box if if it was you
know he said it is his shoulder with you
know two steps
jamie's not afraid to get out there
oh man walk me through this process here
with the quarterbacks and what you're
seeing um you're the one practicing
against him uh walk me through what
you're seeing from the two guys
competing for the that treasured spot to
succeed drew brees's uh starting
quarterback of the new orleans saints
that you can share with me right
i mean with notes you gotta taste the
guy who's gonna you know
uh
take off when he can and really stretch
his field with his feet um
he looks like he's growing from last
year to the first preseason game and at
the same time you also know she's
getting from davis i mean you've got a
guy who who wants to go let's go deep
and he's not shy about it he likes
taking sides that darren quarterback and
you know i think that stretches the
defense um as do who's gonna start i
still don't know you still don't know we
still don't know sean doesn't know
at this point sean doesn't know how am i
supposed to know um but i do know that
you know these two quarterbacks
we can definitely win with we've proven
we can really take so many better what
does nothing but show his growth his
speed and i mean his mental processing
has gotten faster from last year this
year uh we talked about jamison what he
was able to do over example you know the
yardage was allowed
uh drew brees for a year and actually we
saw this past game from the ravens look
damn good so i don't know you know when
it comes down to the quarterback i know
we can focus on what we can control and
that's our defense and i think our
defense
for the better part of the game uh has
shown where we have taken our talents
and how we elevated and how we're able
to elevate our play from the linebackers
to the tv then of course we've got our
guys up front no and and i totally know
and you know and i would never
uh suspect or expect you to or put you
in a position quite frankly about
choosing or telling me about you know
what you're hearing from the coach
because i'm sure he's he's keeping
things close to the vest as you point
out doesn't know but what what uh what i
am curious about
is something that has to be new to you
certainly in new orleans and that is
watching a quarterback competition and
being being obviously your play and that
of the defense can make an effect on
this decision based in what's going on
in practice and and how you go about
that and what you guys talk about and
how how that is to experience
what i'm sure is new for you and what
you can share about that
cameron yeah i mean honestly
prior to this last two years i just said
hey
do you retire is what's gonna happen i'm
gonna hit you with the i don't know
because of the last few years when it
happened where you know we had we
thought bridgewater come
we stress between each other what we
have to do as a defense so it's not that
we don't know what's going on we don't
know what's going on we know that there
can be a championship winning defense
we look at you know when denver won
their super bowl it's not like they were
peyton manning heavy
light reliant they were you know
demarcus swing bond miller it was um it
was the entire defense that they had
back there that really won the
championship defense wins championships
and that's what you hold i have to
that's what we're trying to create as a
regular standard cameron jordan here on
the rich eisen show how is the nfl
different now than when you first came
in i can now ask you this question since
you i mean there's an eli manning
there's a peyton manning there's a drew
brees um they're all gone
right they're still a brady
yeah they're still a brady i mean he's
probably gonna be playing until he's 75
he's
in the phil nicholson of football um
when we think about
everything that we want to do or what
i've seen we're not allowed to hit
quarterbacks too hard anymore you can't
hit him low can't hit him too high you
have to put a pillow down before you
stack him um you're now not allowed to
be excited about football after you look
at this play don't don't directly look
at your opponent and celebrate you have
to probably walk and clear five yards to
celebrate um
officers
are now allowed to push off
defensive players cannot touch there's a
lot of uh oh what are we called
uh
you you're not allowed to really hit
crossing wide receivers anymore now
they're defenseless players i don't know
you tell me rich how much has the game
change well here's the thing with the
taunting that you just referred to i'm
kind of thinking what got called uh in
in in indianapolis against that kid was
it benny lemay right is that who is
chris brockman right now that that that
that that's kind of ridiculous and i
think that's the nfl making sure
that
um is taken yeah and that in that week
one week too you might not see a flag
like that i could be wrong i mean i
could absolutely be wrong here but so is
that is that something that that peyton
shawn is talking to you guys about maybe
the rest of coaches about just walk away
don't stand over the guy if you're going
to
say something just get the hell out of
the vicinity of the player you've just
dominated or taken down that the way
you've been absolutely our are we we got
a penalty i believe in our game on a
third down stop that would got us off
the field one of our one of our
defensive lineman was juiced up about
the play celebrated and next thing i
know it's a flag
down i mean
these are this is something that's
affecting the game and taking some of
the emotion away from the game it wasn't
even as serious as indianapolis coach
running back when all he did was get
excited about him making a hell of a
play i mean he's off the ladder behind
him they pushed the pile another like
eight yards got a first down that's
something to be excited about you can't
be excited about
don't
football
mean hell even dennis players are
allowed to get excited
and that's about as much educational as
you can get
your coach is on the competition
committee you might be able to make a
phone call here you know i mean like uh
he's also an officer-minded coach come
coach
well i was called on an offensive player
in uh in indianapolis as a running back
as you pointed out a great play like he
carried a bunch of defenders five yards
and he's also probably fighting for a
roster spot that's a big play for
somebody like him that's a big
pre-season moment
you know so
you know all right so uh do you have
your pods still you still doing that of
course big trust levels you know we just
uh
just finished up so we're releasing all
of our episodes on every wednesday for
at least the next eight eight or nine
weeks um you know we had guys like
marvin jones keenan
nick saban
oh i'm up on the cast yeah yeah
obviously ingram was the one who booked
him right obviously i mean oh yeah you
know they golf together or something
like that i don't i don't call it much
so i clearly got to get mad you better
get my friendships up across the golf
course how did you what what'd you ask
saban what'd you what did you get from
him
on your podcast oh cam jordan i i
believe that that's how many how much
players could count to 10. but beyond
the sec
um
yeah
how much talent do they have because
then i expected i think i think we've
asked some personal questions
i mean he told me they could count to
11. so i guess that defeated my question
of time okay and we're showing a photo
we're showing a photograph of you here
uh cameron looks like did you change
your hair because there's a big whole
thing with travis kelsey shaving his
beard off did you go
but did you go more corporate here
cameron what's going on i've got i'm
gonna i've got a little part of the
fruit you know
but i would say corporate i just say you
know it's a little it's a little high
and tight right now okay we're we're
going to exactly on the air i mean i had
a chair curl last year you know that
could you can't i don't even know how
dion kept it up for as long as you did
a lot of activator
that's a lot of manicured situations
that i'm i'm so
opposite of high high maintenance well i
mean you're talking to somebody who
hasn't had to worry about his hair in
about 10 years man so you know i don't
know
here i'm i'm with you on that but again
how does that work did uh someone in
your family say let's go different
direction you just looked in the mirror
i said i don't want to have much
maintenance i mean how does something
like this happen for a player oh my god
i love the idea of a journey but
probably until like week four and then i
was like all right this this takes way
too much to get to get right um and then
after offseason i hated my family
clippers and i was like brothers just
have some fun and we he cut you know my
five-year-old cut my hair together but
at the time is that right your
five-year-old
together absolutely yeah yeah you know
just
gave him him uh clippers with a little
one guard on there and just let him go
to work that's some serious trust levels
handing a five handing a
five-year-old some clippers all we do
absolutely if i can't trust my legacy
who can i trust okay so uh if you're
saying that your episodes are all in the
can that means two seasons of this
podcast have gone by without an
invitation to me to appear is that what
uh i'm to understand or about picking am
i picking up what you're putting down
no no see what happened was season one
we focused on just football season two
we started branching out season three
who knows we're going we're
two things two things cameron i'm i you
want to talk about branching out i'm the
branch out okay that when you branch out
that's when you call me and two i just
remember when stuart scott did
sportscenter highlights and there was a
shot of somebody who needed to explain
the unexplainable because he just got in
trouble he would say see what had what
happened was so you just started your
sentence in that way you are if you will
busted not giving me the invitation
which is okay just come straight through
the front door and tell me that's okay i
can take it
look we went ufc we went
uh we went a lit we went an olympic
sensor okay um we even went we we
from aquaman
candy man coming up and yeah yeah
oh he's good
that's the star
we just decided to branch out just a
little bit now
i'll be around cameron
i'll be around all right thanks for the
call you take care we'll chat during the
season okay
look for michael all right there you go
ladies and gentlemen cameron jordan
putting me on the pay no mindless list
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here